and so my i guess my goal is to continue
the conversation from where we kind of
stopped the last one
which is
looking at
i guess in a certain manner what what
the notion of agency is and you know how
that relates to a person but then how
agency relates to other forms of beings
especially kind of uh higher beings the
way that we talked about it let's say or
transpersonal beings sure um that's
really what i guess that's what
we left on a kind of um
cliffhanger on the last talk and i saw a
lot of people in the comments saying oh
no like this is the it was an
interesting part so
i'm hoping to uh to kind of explore that
with you um and so yeah if you're fine
with that we'll go that'd be great i
mean that that uh
so the the talk i gave at cambridge was
based on the work that i've done with
chan chappie and the three papers i
published last year on the nasa
scientists maneuvering the rovers on
mars yeah yeah right all that so that
and then i just did i just did uh my
course um on the nature and function of
the self and of course relationships
between consciousness self and agency
are now fresh on my mind so i'm really
geared to go i'm really good to go
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
all right so maybe i can i can
give you lay out the way that i i see it
let's say and so
i the the first thing that i see is that
from a purely physicalist point of view
there's a sense in which either we we
remove the notion of agency altogether
which i think some people are trying to
do but to me that just seems ridiculous
in the sense that we have a concept
called agency which we something
something like agency which which we've
used to talk about the way in which
humans interact with the world so we
should at least address what that even
if it's an illusion we should see what
that is like what it is that we're
talking about and so it seems like from
a physicalist point of view
if we can attribute agency to a person
then it's it seems like it's odd not to
attribute agency to other beings because
because then human beings
become completely
let's say a freak thing in the entire
cosmos um and so in that sense that's
how when i look at the manner in which
multiple people come together
in order to form units then what i see
is a form of agency which comes back
down on those people and that can use
people as
something like heads
so you have let's say a chief or a
president or a
or a captain or something but that
captain is not acting only out of his
own kind of personal
agency but he is manifesting the
let's say manifesting the rules and the
the
the frame of that being in which they're
participating and so to me that looks
like
in a similar manner in which we do to
our parts like the man in which we
uh interact with our own parts whether
it's our different thoughts our
different
body parts and so we have a captain
you know somewhere like it's it's not
clear exactly
you know how to frame that but there's a
man in which we conceive ourselves as
one in that manner then
creates a form of of a coherence in
other way we act and we interact with
the world so that's kind of my that's
kind of the theory that i'm working with
okay so that uh did you want me to say
something here or did you want to go for
it if you have something that is worth
saying
after what i said
uh so on the first point yeah i mean so
um i think
physicalism trying to do away with
agency is i think is an is a
is an on starter um uh because
uh if
physicalism is premised on the existence
of physics and science in order to
determine its ontology therefore science
must really exist for physics science is
predicated on
rational revision of belief so it
presupposes rationality rationality
presupposes agency in that we correct
our thoughts as we attempt to get at the
truth and if that's not an illusion then
rey rationality becomes an illusion and
then science and then the whole thing
just unravels uh this is why i think uh
reductive uh reductive physicalism um i
think it is
and i if people want to reserve
physicalism for the name uh the
reductive version that's fine that's why
i prefer naturalism right and more and
one more point and it's directly
relevant to what we're talking about in
this argument i just made naturalism
includes not only what is derived from
the sciences but what is presupposed by
the sciences so rationality has to be
part of our naturalistic worldview or we
get into all these kinds of
contradictions so on the first point i'm
in complete agreement and what that
means is we have to acknowledge the
reality of levels other than whatever
like the inverted platonism of
physicalism which is uh the very very
bottom level which is some sort of
abstract probability math somehow
instantiated independent of human beings
is the only really real
we give that up and we have to say no we
have to talk about uh reality being
something that's present on
multiple levels so that's the first
point and so that means right away and
this is something that has been taken up
seriously by 40 cognitive science that
you know as you said organisms have a
reality to them that is more than just
the sum of all their chemical components
or the configuration
and there's a lot of work going on about
that and then the idea of distributed
cognition which is what dan and i
published on the you know and this goes
back to ed hutchins there's no one
person that navigates
an ocean liner it's a bunch of people
and a bunch of tools and they form a
system and they navigate the ship the
same thing with who who's moving the
rovers around on mars well it's no one
person it's a bunch of people and the
rover because it has some ai and they're
all coordinated together in order to do
the science on mars and so
there's a lot of people
dan and i included who take seriously
the idea of we agency and then on the
participatory side i've been engaging in
a lot of participant observation
experiment and design of people getting
into these colo collective flow states
and experiencing something like we level
intelligibility we level intelligence we
level agency so not only theoretically
but also phenomenologically i think
there's converging evidence towards the
reality of what you're talking about now
i want to say one thing which is we have
to be very careful about this
because people too easily skip between
agency personhood selfhood consciousness
self-consciousness and those are not
equivalent terms and we can't just sort
of slide uh between them
in an uncareful way
so
other than that i like i think
there is
a very scientifically legitimate
framework uh uh for talking about
everything you've just been talking
about
okay
i mean and so but i think that my
let's say i'm not gonna hide what my
intention is in trying to no no i
my intention is to try to bridge
something which which until recently has
been very difficult for people to bridge
which is the notion of
higher beings you know whether they're
conceived of as gods or angels as being
patrons of aspects of reality and kind
of
let's say
having a form of
of agency and i and i can i can concede
that that form of agency is not exactly
the same as the way that we experience
agency but there's a manner what i'm
trying to basically get to is the idea
that
that the the transpersonal beings have
an existence they have an existence that
we somewhat participate in by
let's say circumambulating and by
celebrating and by sacrificing two you
know if you think about the mars rover
for example you'll have you'll have
exactly that you'll find all those
elements where the team that you're
working with they kind of have to be
proud of what they're doing and
celebrate what they're doing they also
have narratives sacrifice their
individual whims and individual thoughts
in order to be able to participate in
this this common goal let's say and so
that's really what that's what i'm so do
you see that it is possible to bridge
those two aspects well
maybe
well we'll see i mean i i think there's
definitely
i would definitely want to acknowledge
first of all vertesi one of the
ethnographers um
about the mars rovers and she talks
about how identified uh the scientists
get with they feel like almost a magical
identity with the rovers uh i think i
told you about this they'll be doing
things like they'll they'll say things
like you know i was in my garden and my
right wrist kept getting stuck and then
when i got to the lab you know spirit
pun intended the spirit's wheel was
right wheel was stuck i don't know for
connect like they so there's clear deep
identification so i think the language
of participation is completely
appropriate um
and other thing another thing is for
tessie says
um and i don't want to read too much
into her because she's not here to speak
on her own but but she clearly means
something by this and she unpacks it she
says that the the the rover becomes a
totem uh for became a totem for the
group uh they all saw their identities
as somehow collected into it and they
participate in it and it somehow
transcends them you know in in very much
the way uh you know indigenous people
had totems you know in the durkheimian
sense um
third thing um i know when people are in
these participant practices that i've
been talking about
they they start to talk about something
like a spirit or a
we presence or a logos uh that's there
that
seems to be
directing
the word the language is kind of fuzzy
directing regulating governing shaping
like it's not the same thing as you know
you pushing a table right it's not like
that but there's some sort of sense of
it shaping uh what everybody else is
participating in so that's a first step
in that direction perhaps um yeah
because it's the same with let's say in
terms of pushing a table which is that
there's a sense in which my hand is that
which pushes the table right yes i'm not
the one who pushes the table in terms of
actual physical causes but my let's say
my will participates in that it directs
or shapes the manner in which my hand
will push the table so there's a there's
an aspect in which multiplicity in my
body i can perceive that multiplicity in
my body
um
exists in a in an analogical way to the
manner in which multiple players in a
team or multiple
aspects of a city will come together and
and
manifest their unity and and that's the
original argument uh made for a sort of
extended mind by uh thomas and clark in
a very famous article that has generated
endless controversy although more and
more people in 40 well it's one of the
four e's of 4e cognitive science uh but
their basic argument was like any
argument you for saying well that's not
an agent or a mind you could turn it
inward
and and say well that's not an agent or
a mind either um and so you're making uh
and this is not to discredit you this is
to give you conversion you're making
you know the the the core argument uh
that sort of started the whole idea of
extended cognition like like
are are not the principles of
organization and an action uh relevantly
similar and many people you know and
chalmers and clark are big names and
many people like gallagher and myself
and dan uh you know um i think the
hutchins it's like that's why it's one
of the four e's it's a very it's
considered a very plausible thing now
where where we might have a difference
and i don't know
um is that most people
who talk about we agency and collective
intelligence do not think there is a
consciousness there or any kind of
self-awareness uh and so they talk about
and i think i mentioned this at the end
of the last one they talk about zombie
agency um which is a
funny allusion to both of our previous
work yeah
so that's one of so one that's one of
the the differences now i don't know
maybe i could i the reason why i would
push back maybe is because then if we do
the same like if we if we have the same
experiment with us
you know like do we have real like those
people that talk about zombie agency
what beings do they consider having true
agency
no no no no so sorry zombie agency means
they're real agents but they don't have
consciousness or self-consciousness
that's what's meant
so the idea is many things can have real
agency like for example a mitochondria
is a real agent uh but attributing
consciousness to it seems uh for many
people a very questionable thing to do
and so similarly the idea is um
attributing consciousness to these
supra individual uh
entities
is
like does science have a consciousness
even though there's a scientific
community and we're all working together
and it's constantly deeply interpreted
many people say no that doesn't seem to
we don't have any evidence for that kind
of thing
and so would they limit consciousness
just to the human person is that where
they're no
no
so uh i mean so the the idea is that you
attribute consciousness um to
uh beings that for which you have sort
of clear evidence for a kind of internal
organization
that's analogous to something like our
brain
for example let's use us you can you and
i can both move between conscious and
unconscious states i can give you
propofol general anesthetic and you will
fall out of consciousness right and then
i can bring you out i can reduce the
propofol bring you into consciousness
and then i can note the differences
between when your brain's unconscious
and conscious and say look you need this
it's kind of this uh fractal small world
network organization in order to sustain
consciousness and when you don't have
that right you right you fall into
unconscious and the idea is that you
need uh
you need a certain kind of uh density of
connectivity appropriate structuring of
the communication system so most people
just to finish the point
most people deny consciousness for
example to the crew steering the ship
because the bandwidth and the speed of
the connectivity is too low because if
that was in your brain you would not be
conscious that's that so they they they
take the analogy in both directions
basically
and so the let's say but the
accumulation of connectivity
in the brain to other brains is not
enough to
so not in so it's not an objection in
principle nobody says in principle that
we couldn't get the connectivity and the
bandwidth and the speed it's also a
speed right because uh like it's it's
almost like the five phenomena if the
speed gets too low the things separate
they they they separate out as separate
entities like for example if if i
disrupt your communication between you
and your arm and make it too slow you
will start you'll you will ah right
you'll lose this you'll lose the the
sense of your arm being part of you kind
of thing yeah um
so but there would be a way in which
like uh
let's say if you a city for me is the
best way to think about it because it's
you know it's the closest in my my
estimation to a human being in terms of
analogies is that the speed in which the
communication needs to happen at that
level
is the speed like you said which is
necessary for the beings to continue to
go the let's say the lower beings that
constitute the higher one are able to
coherent to continue to function in
in their purpose and so you're right so
if there's a breakdown let's say in the
email communication between the person
managing the roads and the people doing
it then at some point it's gonna break
apart and then these people are gonna
start to do
whatever they think is right or whatever
they want and then it's not going to
it's not going to it's not going to
connect but if if the
let's say the efficiency and the speed
of the communication
is
is is fine then they'll continue to fix
the roads and continue to do the things
they need to do so it is a reduced speed
but because the being is a different
level the speed doesn't have to be the
same let's say
um
well but there's a difference right your
brain can be highly functional
because most of your processing is
unconscious for example so your brain
can be highly functional without rising
to the level of consciousness so it's
it's something more is needed than just
functional coordination uh because um
there seems to be this other kind of
specific kind of organization that needs
to be in place now i want i didn't quite
get to finish the point you didn't
interrupt me
it's fine but like nobody says in
principle like if
if
this is kind of a weird horror story
and i don't believe that the neural link
that i'm very suspicious of elon musk's
claim because most of the science that
it was based on has just failed to
replicate massively and so it's like i
caught that
but let's say he was let's say he was
telling the absolute truth um and then
we started getting all these neural
links and we could really speed up
then
many people say it's possible we could
get an emerging consciousness that could
be conscious of itself independent of us
so i want to make clear that this the
argument is not an argument in principle
it's just an argument in practice
it says we don't think for example ant
colonies achieve consciousness even
though they collectively solve problems
um because they don't seem to get the
the tight uh and dynamically
interconnected and like like the
massively recursive functionality of our
brain
it seems to be missing
yeah because i mean an ant colony also
doesn't let's say
um
maybe it does i was going to say it
doesn't it doesn't uh change with time
it doesn't have it's doesn't seem to
have an identity
like but a city has an identity like you
can recognize chicago from new york
yeah but to see here's the thing about
identity
like there's a difference between us
attributing an identity and you're right
we don't attribute it to the ant colony
and we attribute it to unique but the
key thing is whether they aren't the ant
colony or new york attributes the
identity uh to itself um right so that's
that requires self-consciousness
and um like i i i i've expressed the
doubts for why i don't think these
entities have self-consciousness yeah
and i mean it's hard it's it's hard to
perceive because we're not at that level
also we're at the level that we are so
we can't it's like it's hard enough to
ver to it's already impossible to verify
consciousness of another human person
directly you only verify your own
consciousness uh
so it's it would definitely be very
difficult to
verify the consciousness of a higher
being because you're not you're not
there like you're just not at that at
that level
uh but it would be it i mean we would
take seriously and this is perhaps where
we differ well whether or not these
events have occurred right um
if
uh you know if that if that agency
started to like communicate uh with us
uh in a self-conscious self-identified
uh fashion right but you wouldn't let's
say if the cell if the agency of the
city would start to
communicate with us we would not we
would receive it at our level so we
would get it as a letter from the city
saying that they're making taxes higher
that's how we would get it
like it would come down that way at the
level let's say of the level of agency
it would it would be at a certain level
but at our level it would be like a new
law or a new rule or a new boundary or
we're going to invade this other country
or we're going to defend ourselves from
this other thing and so it it activates
the
the lower beings towards a new purpose
that the that the city has
contrived or this and there's and i was
thinking about the unconsciousness and
the consciousness i think that i can see
that in a city as well because there's a
level
of functioning in the city for example
that doesn't require high level
sure interaction that just kind of runs
right it just runs but then something
happens like some event that is
unforeseen or a change that needs to
happen and then all of a sudden
everything aligns towards
yeah like i said like you know a new a
new a new tax rate or whatever it is a
new law or there's a problem right you
know there's a there's a problem and it
requires all of a sudden the higher
levels of this of the city to activate
and kind of communicate down
um
and you know that that would happen no
matter who is there
right no matter who the top levels in
the the city are there
that would happen nonetheless so it is
in a way independent from the agents
that are constituting it
right
and and that's
and that's good uh like uh i see the the
the the difficulty that's facing me um
in this yeah and it's not your
difficulty um it's not difficulty with
you that's what i'm saying um is that i
think you all of this makes very good
sense for collective intelligence and i
actually argue that there's an overlap
between the functionality of
intelligence and consciousness that
they're not like this they're more like
this and so your arguments like they
have force for me first of all wanting
to acknowledge that i guess what i have
trouble understanding uh so let me give
you let me give you the reverse case
where most people's intuitions go the
other way so this is a famous argument
by ned block
okay so unbeknownst to you right while
you're sleeping the chinese government
for whatever reason for totalitarian
reasons comes in in the middle of the
night and puts you into a state of pain
and then completely maps out your cortex
right and then they go to china and they
choose china because there's enough
people presumably it's not quite right
but let's say and then what we do is we
train everybody to hold up ones or zeros
at a particular rate to completely
simulate the neurons firing and then
what we do is the population of china is
simulating right by holding up the ones
and zeros right and it doesn't have to
be that they can touch one person or not
touch it doesn't have to be just holding
up cards
and then they completely map out the
same thing and then does that mean that
you've now achieved this sort of state
of pain spread over the chinese
countryside when you ask most people
that they say no there's no pain there
there's just cards going
up and down right because it doesn't
have the right kind of connectivity and
bandwidth and speed
in order to give it the phenomena of
consciousness so do you do you see what
i mean
right yeah i see i see what you're i see
what you're doing but i think it's
because you're trying to take
the like the way in which uh like being
exists in us and trying to bring it up
to the to the higher level but in a
higher level i could tell you how to do
it to bring a country into a state of
pain but i picked pain for reason yeah
pain goes through all the organisms we
we attribute consciousness to from very
very minor worms to us
right it seems to be so there's good
evidence to believe it would be part of
a hyper consciousness as well
it's hard to find in fact i challenge
you to find an instance of consciousness
where you can't find a creature capable
of pain
but
so so it so think of now um
think of i mean wartime is a is a place
where you can see your country
experiencing pain
because what happens is that even that
sometimes the agents that constitute the
country wait what even the agents that
constitute the country will sometimes
not even be directly affected that is
they're not starving if they're in a
part of the country where nothing's
going on there's no bonds going off
where i live but nonetheless this the
state of pain will
will kind of infiltrate the entire
identity of that of that country and so
people will feel pain and anxiety
because they're
in that country even though they're not
no bombs are falling on them at the time
so do you think that's that's a that's
true that that would happen
i i think that people feel empathy
uh but see the problem i'm having is
like when we when we drop to the brain
like the individual brain is not the
individual neurons aren't feeling pain
it's only at the level of the
organization but in the country example
there are individual people that are
suffering and then we express the we we
in ourselves feel empathy towards them
um
like for example if let's go back to the
the china example if every time somebody
held up the one they were in pain then
we'd go oh yeah there's pain spread
across the chinese countryside but
that's not the example the example is
they themselves aren't feeling pain just
like your individual neurons don't feel
pain but they're simulating the
connection while they're enacting the
connection and yet the connection isn't
producing to most people's intuition a
sense of pain
yeah i think i think it's again i think
the same the same issue comes about
which is that
let's think again about a country that's
a war so there there's that say your
capital is being is being attacked it's
kind of horrible to use that now because
we're actually in the war right now but
nonetheless like i think it's still the
best way to understand it like your
capital is being attacked and you live
in the countryside
and so
you
you know that that's you that's being
attacked
and and even though you don't even
though you don't you're not having bombs
rain on you you will your anxiety and
your care will connect you and will
maybe even make you like i don't know
like take up arms and go to the capitol
to to start fighting all of a sudden
because the country is in pain
right so again uh
but the pain of the country is not the
same as of course as the individual pain
isn't it it's it's in a it's a obviously
it's an animal it's analogical there's
an analogy between how let's say a
higher being experiences pain and how
like the beings that constitute it
experience it it's but there's
nonetheless a sense that this is that's
a
going on i don't know
okay so so let me let me try again uh
and and and this is good i think we're
we're we're really honing in um
so
we've got clear evidence
some of it almost frightening that
collective intelligence can solve
problems that individual intelligence
can't so there's more to that than just
the sum of the intelligence of the
participating parts that's how that's
one of the main arguments for we agency
collective intelligence and there was a
really gruesome experiment about a guy
actually wired mice brains together yeah
i heard about that yeah yeah yeah
but anyways and i hope we never have to
do that again and just all accept that
that was done that worked yeah yeah
right okay so right
now
do we have anything equivalent to that
for saying there's a consciousness above
and beyond just the sum aggregate
of consciousnesses of the people that
are in pain
in
like in the war that's that's that's the
missing difference to my mind i
acknowledge like so we
we
we want to acknowledge at least a
distinction between an aggregation and a
real unity just piling a bunch of stones
together as an aggregate yeah right
right and if
i see that there's an aggregation of
pain in the war example but i don't see
the gestalt that transcends the
aggregation
and so let's say there's no so there's
no let's see if there's no aggregation
then what would make
the person in the countryside take a
weapon and go fight in the capitol
what is it that would drive them there
like what what what
no
no i i i i i think i i think it wasn't
clear i think there is aggregation and
what i'm saying is what we want for
like an agent
so we have a we have a we have evidence
for something beyond aggregation in
intelligence
because when you add them together you
get more than the adding of them
together
right and that's why
right and so i'm saying
what evidence do we have that we have
anything beyond just aggregating all the
individual pains and motives of the
people uh in in that particular
situation
well which is that
let's say the person is going to fight
for their motherland
sure that's what they're going to fight
for they're actually not going to fight
for the empathy necessary they have for
an individual
in the city because maybe they don't
even know a person in the city but it
doesn't matter because they they they
get a sense that the my motherland or my
fatherland or my country is being
attacked and so i need to defend that
i'm i'm activating towards a higher
being
and now i want to go defend it because i
am part of it like i am a it is bigger
than me and i and i know that i'm
willing to sacrifice myself for it uh
you may be sacrificing my life for it uh
because i understand that it's what
gives me direction and purpose and and
gives me uh cohesion with my neighbors
and all of that stuff i agree with all
of that i think people can
uh
again i think the entity i'm willing to
agree there's a a motherland right uh
that right that england really exists or
canada really exists and that we can
feel uh well love for that but that's
that's that's the wrong way of the arrow
i was asking i wanna i need to see how
the motherland like like is in pain
itself above and beyond me caring for it
you caring for it like what would be the
evidence for that like the way you can
get evidence right and it's this is a
difficult question i know jonathan
because getting evidence for
consciousness to across the board is
hard and we both agree on that i'm not
challenging i'm not trying to make but
like
i can point to something is what i'm
saying i can point to here's problems
that no individual can solve an only
collective intelligence consult i can
point to them and in those problems
being solved i have to i say that's my
evidence for why there has to be an
agent there because only that agent can
solve those problems okay so i i have a
i have an answer to that and the answer
is
it's a it's a it's a very bottom-up
answer i guess is that is that when we
act as if that being exists
then we get better results as it
from the different from when we act as
if it doesn't exist right
if we act as if there is let's say
france
and that france is
that which binds us that which directs
us that which you know that connects us
that connects us to the past to the
future uh you know that that that
creates a sense of of unity and a
purpose if i act as if that is real and
is a
an agent that acts upon me then i then i
then it will survive no i think you've
got a stronger argument and i'm in
agreement with you yes i think the
stronger argument is right
it's not just that that we like problems
get solved that only uh only something
like france could solve that no no no
smaller set of
just like you can't run the internet on
a computer you have to have a network of
computers to establish an entity like
the internet there's only certain things
that i think they're i think the
evidence
now i i'll be careful i'll have to be i
don't want to misrepresent say everybody
would agree with me but the evidence for
there being you know top-down
agency and collective intelligence i
think that for me
it it i'm not in this i don't think i'm
in any discipline it's the consciousness
part it's a consciousness well
consciousness self-consciousness and
something like personhood
it takes a long time for example even
for a human being uh to become
self-conscious and person um and that
seems to me
and only certain animals seem to be
capable of it highly intelligent
organisms like cats don't seem to rise
to the level of self-consciousness uh
because we have no behavioral evidence
for it right um and so i think you have
to have pretty there's a pretty limited
set of conditions that have to apply in
order for there to be self-consciousness
consciousness um
so there's a manner in which you would
be willing to let's say understand them
as intelligences that exist let's say
but not necessarily as conscious which
which i i'm kind of pushing too because
i don't even in the even in the sense of
let's say the way that uh traditionally
uh angels are understood it's not clear
that they're
that they're conscious they're certainly
intelligences
uh and so your way you if you hear about
the way for example that the fathers
talk about um the fall of the angels
they'll say something like they fell as
soon as they were created like they it
was one time they fell and then that's
their state for
forever because there's a sense in which
they're not capable of change they're
not capable of the type of procedure
that we're capable of so miles i'm also
kind of it's like i'm i'm also not
totally convinced about the
consciousness element of it like i'm
trying to figure out how far i can push
it to see if i can perceive it or
understand it but at least even the
intelligent part is already to me a lot
because i i think that's undeniable
the the the thing you have with
the intelligences is like is you have
like you can have a location problem
that you traditionally don't have for
persons like for example where's the
agent that's doing the rover well it's
on the earth and mars and also
relativistically time delayed by eight
minutes between and like like like and
like you could sort of zoom out and say
well it's sort of between earth and mars
but they're like right and so it gets
very problematic um well maybe agency is
is not a it's not physically located
it well i i think agency
because you couldn't where is it in the
person
well that's the thing right and so uh
but
and but what i'm i i'm not disagreeing
with you on that what i'm saying is
we we seem to pull because personhood
has moral responsibility attached to it
and moral responsibility binds us into
causation like where are you in the room
when agnes died then you could have
killed her kind of thing right because
personhood is bound into morality we
seem to put we we seem to need it to be
limited
like locatable
um in a way that we don't have to have
the same kind of tight location for
agency that's what that's what i was
pointing to
yeah and what what i was going to say
one of the reasons why i i'm kind of
pushing this is just it's actually
because of a statement that christ makes
where christ talks about um he talks
about the city in which he is and he
said woe to you you know it'll be easier
for you it'll be harder for you on
judgment day than the people of of
nineveh that will judge you like the the
the city of nineveh will judge you in
the end so there's a sense in which the
notion that the cities cities are judged
let's say
and that
and so you can kind of understand that
even when christ is saying that he's
he's you can understand he's not saying
that
there's a judgment upon the city that
judgment doesn't actually necessarily
boil down to every single individual in
this city there's a sense in which there
can be a judgment on the city which is
real but that is not
it's not exactly the same as the
judgment that would be on each person
let's say it's like another level of
judgment that yeah that that coexists
with individual judgment that's good
let's play i when you said that i
thought of sodom and gomorrah the
opposite where abraham's bargaining and
if there are like you know 40 righteous
people god exactly for the city so
yeah it separates out
yeah so that that's a very interesting
thing and that we'd actually wrestle
with that um
uh
in re like so for example
um post-world war ii there was a lot
there was a lot of trying to figure out
who do we punish for the holocaust right
who do we punish
um and and we we did some sort of we did
some
we created some myths by the way we the
vermont was clean and it was only the ss
so it was evil and yeah
but attributing that responsibility uh
uh
it's a project that's still ongoing
like as far as i can tell no we haven't
come to uh a final decision about that
like are the german people comp were the
german people complicit they were to
some degree
how much does that matter right that's
really hard i don't know how do you do
that i mean but it's easier it's also
easier to it's harder to like now let's
think of i mean i i i said i wouldn't
talk about politics i told myself that
but you know it's hard not to and so and
so now let's say we're we're
we're putting we put sanctions on russia
right so we're judging russia
and we're applying pressure on the
country yes itself
as a means to
change its course as a means to affect
its it's the direction in which it's
heading and so there's a sense in which
you know where
when you apply let's say a punishment to
the country you're you're not thinking
at an individual level you're not
thinking who in the country is going to
get affected some people will and it's
going to be there's even going to be a
kind of unfairness about the man in
which it falls down onto the people of
the country but there's a sense in which
we have to act against the country
itself in order to affect the direction
uh you know
that it's going and so there's a sense
where you're judging a country or you
could do that for high levels but yeah
so so then let's take it that's a very
good point then let's take it that
our moral judgments um can
apply to the level of collective
intelligence and we agency that did not
immediately translate like
in an identity relation to a judgment on
all of the individuals i think that is
well said um now the pro the issue is do
we require and this this gets really
thorny then and like so
this is fun um
so
do we require only agency and
intelligence to attribute responsibility
moral responsibility or do we
it seems that's all we require or or but
then but then we have the problem
all right
that we tend to think that individuals
are only morally responsible if they
have an act of conscious intention
right
right that's true that's an interesting
point
of that yeah we if there's no if there's
no moral intention we tend to not
attribute blame let's say or we that's
our usually that's at least that's the
the kind of more modern uh
modern system we tend to attribute less
blame at least you know if you kill
someone
deliberately or if you kill someone uh
you know in a fit of rage it's already
not the same and if you kill someone
accidentally then it's not the same
so so classic examples of where this has
come up um and whether or not they're
let's not argue about whether or not the
case was true but you know there there
have been cases where people have been
found innocent uh because they were
sleepwalking when they killed somebody
right so
part of them is like is like a zombie
part of them is an intelligent agent
getting out the knife you know
directing it in the right way like all
that intelligent agency it's it's a
difficult problem to kill another person
right it's it's not it's right and yet
they're they're dreaming about like
they're not they're they're not forming
any conscious awareness or intent
um
so yeah and so but that's a it's an
interesting to think about it so i was
thinking about it recently where
let's say i could say i could say
something like i don't know chicago is
corrupt right i can't say something like
that yeah and that would be true
but it wouldn't be true at every level
like it wouldn't mean that everybody in
chicago is corrupt and i don't think
that
right right i don't think that everybody
in chicago is corrupt obviously not but
i can say something like that you know
and it nonetheless has a truth to it
that when i look at it when i zoom out i
look at
at the identity and i see that there's
something
that there's something there
yeah i agree with you
and uh i'm doing the philosophical thing
of agreeing with you and then noting how
problematic it becomes once we agree uh
because like i said we seem to do we
seem to
we seem to break a principle we when
we're talking about
uh human persons i'll try and because
i'm going to use the word person to mean
a moral agent not just an agent or
intelligent when we right when we we do
it we seem to require the ability to
form a conscious self-reflective intent
in order to attribute at least the most
moral blame but we don't do that uh for
collective intelligence um
and that's really
that's really why
like sorry i really mean that like why
like why what like what like what what
why do we hold that there like if we're
trying to modify the intelligent agency
right that should seem to be the only
like why do we why do we care about
whether or not
the pr i mean we we we do punish people
that don't form a conscious intent when
we find them criminally
negligent for example right um is that
is it like that
you're really making me wonder here
don't i i don't i don't have any clear
or easy answers but this is very messy
ontology yeah actually so maybe we can
keep i mean obviously we could keep
thinking about it because i'm still i'm
in the i'm the same position you are i'm
still thinking about it and still trying
to figure out how it fits but let's say
at the at the least i think that there's
a manner in which
understanding this or at least a notion
of intelligence and agency
can can help us understand that
the way the way of representing the
world
that is more traditional
is in line with this that is that the
ancient way of representing the world
with with with gods and patron saints
and patron angels there's a manner in
which this is
closer to that reality than the one that
we have now which is this kind of
the the the sense in which
we we don't even have a theory like we
do it right we still celebrate teams we
saw mascots we still have all these
things and we rely on this
it's not it's as if it's not part of our
world view but we still do it at the
same time yeah
i i want to acknowledge that right up
there's a performance contradiction um
in thinking that agency is atomic and
individualistic
right and then relying on
you know airlines and
electric grids and the internet and blah
blah blah blah that are clearly cases of
distributed cognition and collective
intelligence what's interesting of
course with something like the internet
is it's this weird blend of humans and
computers that is making it and creating
it and running it and it obviously
transcends any computer it transcends
any individual brain and it just keeps
growing and developing and
and taking on properties and a kind of
complexity there's a i think sawyer
wrote a a science fiction novel that it
you know that that it's plausible that
the internet will actually achieve the
kind of complexity and density and
bandwidth we see in a brain and then it
would start to have a kind of
consciousness on its own which is a
frightening thought um
i think it definitely already has agency
at least i think that's clear i think
that's clear and like i said we were
talking last time in very many ways
people have a a sacred religious
relationship uh to the agency of the
internet they treat it like an oracle
they treat it like a spirit they treat
it like a god um in a lot in in
in in like i find it
funny but in a sort of kafka s way that
people complain about religious
then
interact with the internet through their
phones in they devote hours a day right
and they're paying attention and they're
getting advice and like and like
it's very very religious behavior
yes
and so one of the aspects of the agency
for example i think is a good way to
understand it maybe you can tell me what
you think is
is really even now using a kind of
darwinian
lens which is that
let's say the main the main aspect of
agency is something like
self-preservation at the level of the
being and so
we we can say that the internet has
intelligence to the even to the extent
an agency even to the extent that it
just tries to self-perpetuate and and
the people that are
playing
roles at the lower level the companies
the the you know the tech people
you know they want to cap they know that
the internet exists through attention
and so the entire
the entire the internet itself becomes a
let's say
run by attention
and that and and that attention is what
makes it continue to exist like the more
attention that more people
give to to to the internet in general
the more that it will especially in its
user interface obviously there's a whole
aspect of the internet which is not user
yeah not user interface like wires and
and stuff like that but to the extent
where it interacts with our
consciousness
that's what makes it continue and so
it's as if there's a but the reason why
i'm saying that is that there's a sense
in which we're kind of doomed if that's
the case
because
the the monster or the the creature the
being
it really is asking for worship like
it appears very low at a low level but
as it scales up it becomes more and more
evident that it's asking for something
like worship
um
something like
primal attention
like this is where you get your
worldview this is where you get your
information this is where you get truth
this is where you learn what it means to
be human even almost yes yes i agree
with you
i i think that
um the internet is at least something
like a greek god
in the way it uh uh you know and
encompasses
the like like it's it's not it's not
again it's not in one place it's
ubiquitous i'm not saying it's
omnipresent but it's ubiquitous right
it's ubiquitous and it's uh it's
coordinating people's lives it's
training people's attention it's asking
for devotion it's asking for
identification you identify
with your avatars and your right there's
yes there there's a lot of behavior that
like as soon as you step outside of
familiarity and try to look at it uh
through a more anthropological lens
you'll say well this they clearly have a
religion and their their religion is the
internet but that that i guess the
difference for me is
um
and that's why i use the greek god uh
purposely uh you know the greek gods are
ha uh they had no moral they had no
moral direction that they
just represent sort of primordial powers
and they're important later on
under the pressure of platonism and
others they started to become moral
agents but initially they're not um
and so i guess
that's what i i was trying to convey
when i think the internet is like a
bronze age deity right it's it right
it's it's it's like seth of ancient
egypt or something it's this it's this
power
um that people identify in and with and
does all the things we're talking about
but it doesn't have um
it doesn't have a moral directedness to
it it's not an it's not an agent
that is self-organized towards helping
us
uh become wiser
um which i think is that's an important
difference yeah it's i mean it is like
you said it's it's more it's looking for
propitiation and it's and it's looking
to be satis it's looking for
to capture to capture us so that we
could because we can sit constitute its
body in a certain in a certain way like
in the same way that if you understand
the way a greek god would function is
that the greek god would have temples
with people sacrificing animals to the
god in order to provide body for that
god in the world like places where they
they step let's say and they they have
anchorage and so we are that's what we
are for the internet we're basically the
anchor because without us the internet
obviously doesn't
the internet needs us as a body but i
think also the greek gods and the
ancient gods needed humans as a kind of
body you know
in order to celebrate them and to make
them
to ha let's say that there will be done
in the world you needed humans and casts
of priests and all these things that
would enact the the
enact the the identity of the god in in
reality
yeah and i think that i mean speaking as
a naturalist i think that was the
reality of but it still is i'm not
saying i believe in zeus or but you know
there's a sense in which ares is is is
taking shape in ukraine right now right
and and you know and war is this thing
right it's maybe the
pathetically maybe it's the most
collective thing we do um which and so
thinking that war can't take on a life
of its own uh look look we are terrified
not unjustified that if we do anything
wrong this will spin off yeah and esca
right and who well no one person is
gonna make that happen and that ability
for things to spin off and consume us
that's ares that's the greek god aries
or eros eros like if you don't believe
that eros is real like wow i don't know
what like i don't know what that means
um so yeah
and i think the internet is like that so
i guess the the the uh so
can i ask you and i mean
like what like uh like
why is this like important like what why
does it why is it important no no no no
no no no no
that's not an insult i i i don't know
not at all no no no i as a cognitive
scientist i'm very interested in this
with we're really trying to understand
intelligence and agency and and that and
so i want to know what your like what
your interest is in it
well i think that my interest is really
to be able to help people understand and
not only understand but participate in a
proper manner
in the way in which the world exists and
so
if we understand that the world actually
exists this way and if i can convince
people who at least until recently were
materialists or physicalists that this
is actually how the world works then how
do we do it properly what's the best way
to engage with the reality of higher
beings and their and their agency and
their intelligence what's that what's
the most appropriate way and like you
said there's a man in which you can see
you know the world of tribal gods that
existed you know in the ancient world
and how what that led to and what that
brought about even human sacrifice and
and and uh
a very a very dark reality you know
often that involved sex and involved all
kinds of stuff that was going on in
order to give body to these to these
gods um and so the question is once we
realize that this is
so i i would go as far as to hope that
people can understand for example
something like
if you sacrifice
to a god
it works
like it's not just a thing people do for
like just for fun or for whatever it
actually will engage the agency of the
god back into the world if you sacrifice
to a higher entity like it's harder for
people to understand the idea of
sacrificing an animal fine like let's
just keep it to attention for now at
least for people could not understand if
you sacrifice something precious that
you have your attention or your money if
you give your money to a cause or if you
give something to a higher higher being
then that will engage it back down into
reality both by your dedication by your
attention but also by the fact that
you're willing to sacrifice something
precious for it to actually exist
um
so that's really what i why it's
important to me because i feel like
this is a bridge that a lot of people
can kind of see in front of them they're
not totally willing to to cross yet but
that if they can cross it then we can
reconnect
i think as much as possible the the
religious world with the scientific
world
that we can help people even scientific
minded people understand that they are
already religious that they do these
things but they do it unconsciously in a
little me in a messy manner but that
there are ways to engage in a more
proper and a more you know like you said
the ancient gods
they didn't they they didn't care about
you like they just wanted their they
wanted to be fed and then maybe you
would get something from them but
there's a manner in which that
transformed with time then you get to
religions uh like like christianity and
within other religions as well that
understand that at the top of all of
this there's love
and that that is what has to kind of
come down into these different ages and
that we do conceive that there are
agents that are different that are
demons that are wild and have their own
will and will suck you into themselves
and will kind of devour you and we
understand that but we also
want people to reorganize their
attention and their will towards that
which leads towards infinite love you
could say um so that's that's really the
purpose of that's why i care about this
so much
that's that's very helpful thank you
um i might want to recommend i will i
recommend that you might want to read
lerman's book how god becomes real uh
don't be put off by the title uh because
she's talking about you know
uh the different kind of reality that
these agents have
um and she's a great anthropologist
um and she's basically arguing
that
we have different senses of real
um and we can't use the real we apply
when we talk about a rock being real for
how these things are real and and we're
we're already getting that i mean
i think evolution is real that doesn't
mean i can point to it there it is
there's its location right and like it
like it's a hyper object you use
morton's term
and so i guess that's one thing i want i
want to bring up
now that that's why lerman came to mind
first of all to recommend the book to
you
but there's also a notion of aspects of
reality there there are hyper objects um
uh
let's say like like say evolution or
global warming um like you can't there
it is or there it is or like it's right
but but but you can't say well it's not
real so it's not an object this is why i
call it hyper object now dan and i have
been making the argument that it takes
something like
distributed cognition to be able to come
into a
realization of
of these hyper objects like
right like for example global like no
one person can become no one person can
perceive global warming you need people
all over the globe and all these
equipment and all these computers before
you can say oh there's the real pattern
do you understand
what i'm trying to point out uh and so
i also wonder if there's a sense in
which uh
uh i'll try this and i'll probably
mungle it but this idea that these
collective agents
also
uh give us access
to
real patterns that we couldn't have
access on our own does that did that
make sense i'd like like you're right
okay okay it makes sense like if you
think of uh
leaving at a smaller scale like if you
think for example of uh even of a famine
for example or of a war is the same
thing
where you need these these higher beings
to understand that it's not just me
that's dying of
hunger
yeah right i need to be able to to
perceive at what scale this is happening
and then in order to engage it properly
then like you said there has to be a
scale a scale at which it makes sense to
act a level at which it makes sense to
act in order for these these hyper uh
whatever you you call hyper objects to
be dealt with yes
yeah like there's there's there's
phenomena that are real
that affect us but don't don't affect us
the way physically
like spatial temporally limited objects
affect us like tables and chairs and
rocks and things like that evolution and
global warming and you know economies
economies are hyper objects like you
know like yeah
i i think that the fact i think the fact
that you separate those to me is what
maybe surprises me because to me
like all beings are constituted by let's
say
an identity a pattern
and a body
and that that body does it could be
subtle it doesn't have to be
physical like right so a story
has a pattern and a body
but its body is not is also it's not
it's a subtle body it's not a it's not a
physical body let's say um and i think
that that's true of just all beings so
the idea that they're like a table is
also that like a table
has a pattern
and a purpose
and that's how you can recognize that
it's a table and engage with it as if
it's a table so so does global warming
let's say it's just bigger or it's just
just not it's not
it's not at a level that i can perceive
at a glance with my eyes
um but uh like it's a uh
there are other types of beings that i
don't necessarily perceive with my eyes
but that have
that have being
right right the point i was making was
not an ontological point i think that
they're all real that's the point so i
wasn't making any kind of ontological
distinction i was making
i was i was making a an epistemic
distinction to try and explain a kind of
confusion
which i i thought might be helpful to
your project because i think what i'm
saying is
and this is you know you can see this in
marla ponti and others and obviously in
plato right is that uh you know
and sandy makes this argument about
plato's permanentes is that we use the
familiarity of how we realize
perceptually limited specifiable
temporal spatial we use that as the
universal standard of being real and
that actually blinds us to the idea that
to to realizing that there are many of
these realities that can't be
uh grasped in that manner that's what i
would that's what i would so i i guess i
i'm sort of suggesting to you that part
of the problem
that your project is facing is that
you're not just i mean one part of it is
a truly philosophical metaphysical thing
and we're talking about it here but
another might be a confusion in your
audience in that they are bound to
a
the attribution of
like kind of a very simplistic
nominalism only raw spatial temporal
objects exist and everything else is an
illusion i mean that seems to me to be
possibly also what is perhaps thwarting
you um is that a possibility uh maybe i
mean i'm hoping that most people that
listen to me by now like they they're
past that i hope so it's possible that
there's still people that are there
because i see it some people are
confused when i say things uh sometimes
when i say certain things exist and
they're like what how can you say that
that exists uh that there are different
matters in which things exist
um i think that like for me
the
let's say for me the the biggest
obstacle i think is finding
a language that would make it
understandable and appropriate to talk
about how being stacked up and scales
towards higher
higher beings and higher agencies to
find a way in which
in which people can because it's
difficult like the difficulty is this
like if i talk about angels
then then people think of
people have such fantastical ideas of
what angels are like it's all science
it's all fantasy and it's all weird
ideas of people with angels that exist
in other dimensions or whatever it is
that they think so it becomes almost
impossible to use those terms anymore
because all of a sudden people
think of angels as physical beings that
are invisible basically is what they
think yes and so how what language can i
use to help people bridge back into a
more traditional vision of what of what
higher beings are higher
cesar
i'm going to push back on you a little
bit not in the context i totally agree
with that project and i i i hope we can
continue to be partners on it because i
i think i mean that's what i mean about
the neoplatonic courtyard as a poll as
opposed to the the courtroom of debate
like getting this kind of ontological
framework that allows us to do this
however the pushback is this and this is
something that
again i've
been deeply impressed upon me by plato
and marlo ponte how difficult it acts we
can know this sort of propositionally
but act like
i think it takes transformative
practices to let go of the ray of firing
mind
right
you know and i'm reading maximus and i
see that in him i see that obviously in
dionysus right
it's all through plato right it's like
like we can like in the parmenides play
socrates knows the theory of the form
and but parmesan comes in and crushes
him because although he can make all
these arguments he's clearly still
working within that that rarifying
grammar
you know yeah right now i see what you
mean
right yeah that in fact
in order to perceive this it's not about
thinking and arguing it's about
participating through
like mystical prayerful uh practice that
would actually make you and biological
practices yeah because that's where i
see people getting i don't i don't i
don't want to put them i don't want to
put them exclusive i think you need to
be doing both and they need to be sort
of helping each other along the way
that's what i'm that's what i'm
proposing
yeah that makes that makes that makes a
lot of sense um but i think you've
already you you've already kind of
helped me to
to understand what the issues are and to
kind of to kind of push in a way but
even like the
the consciousness aspect is one which i
was i'm trying to push against and
trying to to see if there are ways to
perceive consciousnesses at at those
levels but it's like i realize that even
in the fathers
there seems to be some ambiguity about
about that you know and you see it in
even i've read some some rabbis let's
say the way they talk about angels as
well and there seems to be some
ambiguity about whether or not we could
say they're conscious in the way that we
are
conscious let's say there's more but
they're definitely intelligences that
are agentic but they don't have
they don't have this they might not have
the kind of self-consciousness that we
that we tend to that we experience we're
not sure
yeah
and uh you know and then we have to also
be worried
uh along with that ambiguity we have to
be worried about anthropomorphic bias
right um
and
um
but that doesn't the anthropomorphic
bias doesn't bother me so much in the
sense that
i i tend i think that it it seems that
it seems as if
there's probably a reason for that like
there's a reason why we view
reality through the mirror of our own
of our being right where we tend to
project
the human
a level of reality into different levels
of reality
because that's the level where we are
like there is no other we don't know of
another point of consciousness by which
we can interpret the world this is the
only point of consciousness that we know
and so we
we tend to use that as the measure we
could say of other beings
and i think that that is somewhat
inevitable maybe not not that big of a
deal
well i mean let me uh i mean the
anthropomorphism can be a little bit
more
specific let me try and give you an
example of where i think it can be
problematic
we sort of figured out
at least in our culture i don't want to
presume on other cultures
that children are actually not just
little adults
right uh uh
only sort of
you know in the last couple centuries i
mean if you go back to earlier periods
john locke for example thought the only
difference was just how much information
they had in their brains and things like
that and so i mean that's an example
also of a version of the anthropomorphic
that every every human exactly is an
adult
and they're not and and and it it's it's
been i think very i think
not that there hasn't been uh negative
consequences but i think on the whole
realizing that children aren't little
adults has been a very positive thing
for children um in terms of how we treat
them and educate them and things like
the fact that they used to try children
and convict them of crimes like we
things that we would find like
horrendous nowadays right um um things
like that that's what i mean about we
can we can we can
we can overestimate how
much things are like us too
yeah that makes sense definitely
definitely
um
listen i think i need i think i will now
need to think about all our
conversations
but i i think it's great i think it's
great
i really feel like i'm kind of moving
i'm moving i'm moving forward and trying
to you're the best person to kind of
put my arguments against and so i i
think that's that's good likewise i mean
uh like
there's enough of i hope you don't take
this as any kind of insult there's
enough of a sort of shared neoplatonic
uh outlook that allow us to get into
some very good discussion but there's
enough differences between us two that
we both also uh you know generate
insight in each other and i think that's
really good i think that's really good
definitely definitely all right so we'll
have to uh i have to keep thinking about
it and we'll have to organize another
another discussion at some point yeah
yeah because uh there's one thread i'd
like to come back to at some point
which you made and you made a point i
didn't challenge it and i didn't mean to
challenge it i don't want to challenge
it i want to explicate it the idea of
meaning in life as this sense of being
connected
and one of the problems like if you go
to susan wolf's right being connected to
something bigger than yourself right and
right and then she says but there's
things that she doesn't think there's
any objective reality
to that and that's the problem facing us
but you said you know people get a
meaning in life because they're
connected to this
and what if it does have at least a
semi-autonomous kind of existence then
that relationship is a real relationship
it's not just a if
it's not just an as-if relationship and
that might say something about
the project of meaning in life about
this kind of connectedness to these
kinds these kinds of transpersonal uh uh
agents
yeah that makes sense but also you could
understand that even
let's say that that would
come even as your your your ex your
experience as a child and having a
relationship with your parents and you i
think that probably as a child you would
almost experience your parents as
trans personal and descent as higher
beings than you like you said
you see them as these these higher
things um
and so it wouldn't make sense that also
then that would
be an image like the idea that god is
our father would would make sense in
that in that way yeah if it makes sense
even in terms of our actual experience
of how we experience authority and how
we experience our fathers as children
exactly and theoretically that might
mean there's deep connections between
attachment and meaning in life the kinds
of connections might be more similar
than we usually think they are i think
that's a very interesting idea to
consider
yeah
but then you can see also how someone
who i mean you can also see how it goes
awfully wrong like he kept wanting all
these examples right so how can go
completely completely off the rails
which is of course the the danger of
attachment to oh totally right just
just like i think you can't reduce
meaning in life to morality um i don't
think you can reduce morality to meaning
in life like you either reduction is a a
serious
missing and a serious mistake yes i
totally agree with that yeah and and
it's interesting because attachment to
higher
purposes is not the same as morality
right there is a morality to it like
ultimately you would want those higher
purposes to be right you know to be true
let's say yeah in the moral sense but
then you can all obviously you can you
can you know people everybody knows
people or it's happened to you where you
get involved in a higher purpose that is
just pointless or
either pointless or even dangerous you
know or not not good for you or for
others
yeah and and i mean this gets uh chris
and chris master pietro and i are
working on a new series of socrates and
kirkegaard and now we're bumping up
against the teleological suspension of
the ethical um right and so
yeah well anyways i'd like to talk to
you about that at some point right like
to what degree does meaning in life
depend on people
coming into
resonant living relationships uh with
uh these higher order agents uh does
that make life more meaningful if it
does how and why what are the dangers
there's a way in which at least the way
it's expressed in christianity is really
is interesting in say maximus for
example like there's a sense in which
the bond of love you have towards god
is
expressed in the bond of love you have
towards each other right that's what
christ says and so there's a sense in
which the
you know let's say the love you have for
your neighbor
is the manner in which now you're
attaching yourself to these higher to
these higher beings and so it's like a
there's a
that's the how the scalability happens
like you bind together and then that if
you bind together towards
towards
something which is above you then it all
kind of works because you you know and
everybody knows of uh that they have a
higher purpose that actually like a
vampire that
sucks the energy from all the other
things inside and then just discards
them as it moves forward you know it's
like a kind of pathological organization
that just sucks the energy and doesn't
create the bond inside in order to make
a real kind of fruitful body you could
say
that's very cool
yeah
yeah i i guess
so i want to talk about that and also uh
like the other thing because we most of
the discussion and
quite rightly so has been sort of bottom
up but there's a sense in which right
there's a there there there has to be
some discussion of what's what's the
top-down aspect
of of these things right yeah
uh
i mean that the top the top top down
aspect is
mostly identity
and that sounds like it's a weird it's a
weird thing for people they think like
why why does that matter but it's mostly
it gives you
it makes it's that what makes you
participate
and so
there's that and purpose like a purpose
like higher purpose and higher identity
is what is what comes from above
but there's also i i agree um
um
i get my question was a little askew um
yeah what i meant is we sort of got like
there's all these causal interactions
right all the soldiers are fighting and
that makes aries but there's also all
kinds of constraint
like factors
that also
make that make that take the shape it
does right like so the analogy i'm
getting like you've got like you you
have to have all these
environmental constraints for a tornado
to take shape the tornado is actually
driven by heat and all that stuff and
the motion but you also have to have all
these differences and constraints in
place um that's what i'm trying to get
at uh and i like and you can think about
like something really interesting with
your city exam you've got all the people
and they literally make laws but then
the laws constrain the people and then
like you get bottom-up top-down stuff
happening
that's what that's what i that and i
want to press that analogy to other
things
yeah definitely i mean i i that's
definitely something i'm interested in
for sure
i mean i i actually i mean i tend to
think top down and more naturally
the last five years of my life has been
has been like an experience
in trying to express this bottom up as
much as possible to kind of get people
to understand what we're talking about
but uh but definitely the top down part
is important to explore
and i think the bottom up and the top
down are equally scientifically valid
like they're equally scientifically
legitimate and important yeah and but
i'm happy to see you reading maximus
because i feel like at least my in my
experience is that in maximus you really
have one of the best expressions of how
those two kind of come together how
they're
they they depend on each other right
they there's a sense in which
the bottom up you know expresses i mean
my brother talks about it in his book by
the way very very well right it's like
there's informa the the top informed on
the bottom embodies or or supports you
know and that these two things must
happen at the same thing time for
reality to
to to manifest let's say
yeah i'm trying to read all the great
synthesizers maximus
i'm reading balthazar's uh
biography on him as well
um and obviously aquinas especially the
new
neoplatonic interpretation of aquinas
um and of course uh regina
uh yeah yeah yeah i know you you talked
about him quite a bit before yeah and so
and it's amazing to me how
um
uh you know how all of these
these great synthesizers seem to be
converging up they they obviously have
important differences and for christians
i know those differences are doctrinal
and kinds of things and but but there's
also a deep convergence on this shared
ontology and i think that's really
something that's really catching my
attention i'm really i'm really trying
to let myself follow that as deeply as i
can right now
that's great yeah i mean i'd love to
hear more about that too so
we'll have to yeah we'll have to set it
up quite soon another conversation
well i i
i think we're sort of drawing to a close
now but uh this has been
really really really good um
um i always look forward to talking to
you i think it always goes in wonderful
places um so
definitely i do i hope we get a chance
to be in the same place again you know
soon
it feels like as things are kind of
falling down all the the mandates and
stuff like that seems like it could be
more possible
uh yeah i hope so i mean i hope someday
still that you and i and paul get to be
physically co-present and and do
something
so that would be wonderful i would
really love that so yeah all right john
it's good to talk to you
excellent talking to you thank you my
friend
as you know the symbolic world is not
just a bunch of videos on youtube we are
also a podcast which you can find on
your uh usual podcast platform but we
also have a website with a blog and
several very interesting articles by
very intelligent people that have been
thinking about symbolism on all kinds of
subjects we also have a clips channel a
facebook group you know there's a whole
lot of ways that you can get more
involved in the exploration and the
discussion of symbolism don't forget
that my brother matsuya wrote a book
called the language of creation which is
a very powerful synthesis of a lot of
the ideas that explore and so please uh
go ahead and explore this world you can
also participate by you know buying
things that i've designed t-shirts with
different designs on them and you can
also support this podcast and these
videos through paypal or through patreon
everybody who supports me has access to
an extra video a month and there are
also all kinds of other goodies and
tiers that you can get involved with so
everybody thank you again and thank you
for your support